hey both whalers welcome to what I'm
sure is going to be one of many
unboxings for fallout stuff over the
next couple of weeks and in four just
yet but here we have the fallout
anthology which includes you can say
almost every Fallout game it's got
fallout 1 2 tactics fallout 3 game of
the Year Edition and Fallout New Vegas
Ultimate Edition so it doesn't have
Brotherhood of Steel on the PlayStation
2 or a copy of that iPhone game but it's
got pretty much everything else and also
it comes in this ridiculous mini nuke
which isn't as heavy as it looks
I'll be honest and I don't know if it
actually fits into a Fat Boy or not but
uh it seems it seems pretty legit I like
it I like the finish huh and we pop the
top here ACMA dinner dad would be very
displeased because inside is not
enriched uranium it is in fact leaflet
for doom a leaflet for fallout anthology
anthology and then this little guy which
is a bunch of little loose leaves with
what I have to imagine is download codes
because this is empty I'm gonna under
I'm gonna guess let's see let's see
about fallout 3 maybe that's got a disc
in there is I got this what's in here
let's go to this it's got of this
alright so maybe they do all of this so
yeah the game the game aspect itself is
a little bit a little bit on the skimpy
slide but this thing doesn't actually
cost that much money either and we've
seen people selling them for double the
price on some websites but you should be
able to pick this up for the Bethesda
store for 50 bucks and it's available
right now unlike its brother fallout 4
in fact if you look at the back of this
box it does say fallout 4 sold
separately says a right there in the box
you do not be fooled this anthology
includes one two tactics at the game of
the year edition of fallout 3 and the
ultimate edition of fallen new vegas and
it also includes this
[Applause]
yeah teaching all that money this is
gonna make Bethesda Softworks
and that's your unboxing of Fallout
anthology right here gamespot.com stay
tuned for more unboxings and more
coverage of the Fallout universe
[Music]